we're still looking at long days without
food or drink for the remainder of the
months but like a bolt from the blue
Ramadan will be gone but with every
cloud there's a silver lining because
come rain or shine a slam will enter
every home just like our prophet
forecasted he said Allah will not leave
a household residence but that he will
cause this religion to enter it it's
just a tip of the iceberg this is an
opportunity to help share Islam across
all corners of the earth
we're expecting heavier downpours of
donations towards the last 10 days with
them flooding during the odd nights I
don't have the foggiest for literacy
another day Saad Act lightning fast and
donate today to brighten up someone's
day by giving them the gift of Islam
donating to our era is not a long-winded
process it's a bracelet
don't be saving for a rainy day donate
today for the price of less than a cup
of coffee a day and receiving the words
of people accepting Islam across the
globe soompi on your scales and day of
judgment imagine now someone accepts
Islam every will go that they do every
prayer that they pray and every letter
of Quran that they read what are you
waiting for what are you waiting for
imagine the reward
and click the button and donate today
[Music]